you know Pedro Pascal because you guys
are kind of wow in the daddy verse
together we are so today we're here for
Gran Turismo okay so tell me who you're
playing in this movie
um I play basically it's a true story
about a kid who played this Gran Turismo
video game and then Nissan held a
challenge where they let these you know
video game kids drive real cars and then
this one kid like wins the whole shebang
at the end so there's a guy who trains
them
who is like the chief engineer and Coach
and he's very skeptical let's say at the
beginning and then sort of becomes a
really feel good sports movie along the
way but he himself has some Secrets as
well so I play basically the chief
engineer and coach of these kids did you
get to get behind the wheel at all
I did a little bit of driving sure yeah
I mean you don't see it you see a little
bit in the movie I drive a safety car uh
a lot of the race car drivers will drive
these cars and sometimes they'll be
following around by safety cars the
funny thing about them is the um the
race cars have paddle shifters they
don't have a clutch but the safety cars
all have clutches and we're uh manual
transmission so I much prefer driving
the safety cars right and I drove those
much too fast much to the Chagrin of all
the insurance people on set like Harbor
very disappointed in me very
disappointed like please please that was
my that was my name I wanted to be a
race car driver when I was really wow
what happened I'm on Look at me now well
if you weren't an actor what would you
be doing I would not be driving race
cars that is for sure
no it's not my favorite thing I mean
it's interesting like it's fun in the
movies but it's a real violent thing
like you're out there in the pits and
the cars are like screaming in really
fast and these drills they use have such
power like these pneumatics and stuff
that like take the wheels off and the
gasoline and the rubber on the road and
just the smell of the asphalt and
everything it feels really violent it
was the first week or so I was very
freaked out by the whole experience so
it's not my favorite thing but it's you
know it's great to watch like from afar
intense yeah every time I talk to you
it's something cool I mean red Guardians
coming back you're doing Creature
Commandos stranger things yeah I mean
where do I start how are you feeling
about stranger things coming to an end I
mean you know ready I think I think
we're ready I mean it's bittersweet of
course because it changed all of our
lives and also I'm such a fan of the
show always have been and continue to be
and I think those guys The Duffer
brothers are real geniuses but just
because it's the end of stranger things
doesn't mean it's the end of them
creatively and I feel like they'll go on
to create other things that are gorgeous
and that will fall in love with as much
as stranger things so it is the end of
one thing but the beginning of possibly
a new chapter that's just as beautiful
yeah and I was wondering when Red
Guardian was coming back Thunderbolts is
a really cool kind of unexpected place
um how are you feeling about joining the
squad I feel like last time we talked
you were like I don't know I haven't
read the script yet I really like what
they've pitched me so far uh even though
I haven't seen a full script what do you
know now I read the script
it's real good it's just really good I
mean Marvel's changing it up you know
um they're always surprising but this
team in particular and what they're
doing what this means in the universe is
a its own thing that's really
interesting but the team itself and the
way the movie comes together is uh very
different than any other Marvel movie
I've seen
um I'm the director is this young guy
Jake who did this beef show it's really
smart guy uh and the whole thing is just
it's just really exciting I can't wait
to get started I will say Gran Turismo I
played that game on PlayStation one
um video game adaptations are
notoriously difficult to do what do you
think was the the Special Sauce that
makes this movie work I mean the fact
that it's not a video game
interpretation it like there is a hugely
successful like I'm loving the last of
us they really killed it with that show
did you know Pedro Pascal because you
guys are kind of wow in the daddy verse
together we are we occupy a certain
Realm of the daddy the realm yes yes no
no I know him very well actually uh but
um yes they're doing some interesting
stuff but in general I'm video game
movies are really hard and when they
sent pitched me this idea they were like
we're making a thing of Gran Turismo I
was like that's the dumbest thing I've
ever heard because it's just a simulator
like what are you gonna do stitch
together some dumb story about you know
but the thing is it's a real story of a
kid who played this video game and then
wound up uh winning Le Mans so it's a
sports movie I mean it's Hoosiers it's a
miracle it has this real feel-good
sports movie in it and then you have
Neil coming in with all his video game
knowledge and all his sci-fi stuff so
you have that same sort of feel when
you're in the car that we give you that
experience but at its Essence it's an
emotional like
um sports movie it's not a video game I
love it yeah thanks so much David
[Music]